I want to start with how much I enjoy
your work and I appreciate all the long
hours you must put in to create your
music so I just want to say thanks
um I'm so I'm so curious how do you know
when something is actually done because
I I what goes through your head do you
like is there like a feeling you're like
oh this is it or are you constantly
tweaking I would say constantly tweaking
to the very very very very very very
very very end and in this one you know I
was literally listening to the final
mixes of the of this of the score
yesterday so
uh yeah it's it's uh you know as much as
and that's what that's also what's so
special with having you know I'm very
lucky to have like these collaborations
that I have with these incredible with
the incredible directors and artists you
know I Ryan and I have been working
together for almost 13 like 14 years now
so which means you know uh that we have
he gets me involved very early in the
process on the script level he sends me
the first first version of the script so
that means I have a lot of more time you
know I can start experimenting at a very
early stage and send him ideas while
he's shooting and he sends me ideas when
he's shooting so we haven't constantly
having this creative conversation with
each other for for years before the
movie comes out how much are you able to
look at the dailies and everything as
it's going and how much is it sort of do
you know what I mean like or are you
waiting to see what it's all going to
look like at the end no I'm I'm I'm I'm
starting on the script level like I I
went as soon as I read the script I set
off to try to start envisioning what it
sounds like no totally I I totally get
that what I'm saying is are you also
looking at dailies as they're shooting
to sort of alter or is it sort of like
you're you're composing with the script
and then you're waiting to see what the
Cut's gonna be yeah I'm waiting
unless there's like specific things that
I need to hit with with like if there's
if there's on-screen musical performance
or something I can see days but
otherwise I prefer to just kind of write
on the script and wait until they have
uh a cut I've spoken to some people that
really like to be laser focused on one
project at a time and not sort of
clutter their brain with a ton of things
how are you are you able to do like four
projects at the same time or when you
were working on black panther 2 was it
just black panther yes yeah I was I was
you know fortunate enough to be able to
I've done a lot of that I think in my
career uh when and and before
you know I I earlier on in my career I
was working on more things at the same
time as doing songs or doing TV shows
doing movies and and I think at that
time I just I just
I and my brain maybe worked a little bit
different and maybe had different also
priorities but but the last couple of
the last couple of projects I've done
I've been fortunate enough to to be able
to uh understand the way I really love
to work which is to do one project at a
time and be laser focused on that and
and go 200 and and spend all my uh brain
power and my emotional and and my
creativity on that
um so did you officially finish black
panther 2 yesterday
no I've finished it I finished it a
while I finished it a couple of couple
weeks ago but but the just the the
soundtrack and the the score CD there's
there there I had to listen to some
mixes I I completely understand did you
feel more this movie mean the sequel
means a lot to a lot lot of people
and everything with Chadwick like
there's just a lot of emotions with this
movie and I'm curious if you applied
more pressure on yourself making this
because of how much this movie means to
so many people absolutely I I felt it
was a very it was a challenge
um you know after after the passing of
Chadwick
you know if just imagining what the
music would sound like without him and
because
there were so many musical moments and
instruments and sounds and themes that
was tied to his character in The First
movie
so
are we going to be able to reuse those
themes are we getting able to use the
talking drum which is you know
constantly played throughout the whole
first movie you know that that was as
soon as you hear that sound you
immediately think of of t'challa and so
just had to be very thoughtful about
like okay well how because it means so
much to so many people and it has such
an emotional weight to it so I that was
that was something that would
meticulously spend time on and and
thought about in in ways where they
would feel feel the best sure by the way
I haven't said it yet but I think the
sequel's like fantastic obviously your
music is great uh it's gonna be this
huge hit but while I have you I'm also
what we call a Star Wars fan just
throwing that out there uh I have to
know you don't work on Endor but are you
watching it I haven't seen it yet no oh
I'm gonna I'm gonna recommend you
watching yeah I'm excited I'm really
excited about it I'm super excited about
it yeah yeah I strong recommendation
this Tony Gilroy guy seems to be pretty
good but uh jumping into why uh I have
to know um obviously Mandalorian season
three comes out early next year at some
point uh where are you in the recording
process have you started are you working
on it
we'll have to keep that a secret
sorry
I understand
um then I'll ask you this uh what did it
mean because I loved your work and
tenant and getting to work with Nolan
what did it mean to you to get to
collaborate with him because he's such a
gifted filmmaker and just like Ryan you
know just a very special filmmaker can
you talk about that collaboration I mean
yeah it's it's
you know I'm I feel very very fortunate
to be able to work with with with with
both Ryan cooler and Chris Nolan like
these directors are so completely
devoted to to
to to there's so there's a completely
devoted to the Arts and you know it's
it's it's I don't feel like
it doesn't that doesn't really feel like
we're making a product it feels like
we're you know we're making you know
we're both all trying to make something
Timeless and something you know we're
trying to create something uh art you
know and and
just some and I I it's and obviously
grow I've been like the way that Chris
thinks about music and also and and
they're both Ryan and Chris are so they
have such a mute and an ear and interest
for music and you can tell in their
filmmaking and and I've been a fan of
Christmas movies since I was very young
and like the the importance that he puts
that he has that he lets the score has
in his movies the weight of the score
and how connected is to the storytelling
you know and it's it's it's all about
creating that immersive experience and
and I remember seeing you know Batman
Begins for the first time and in the
theater and just sitting there as you
know it's like completely encapsulated
by by the by the by the music and by the
movie and how they work so well together
and and just yeah just just I also
everything that that we're trying to do
and that we did with tanning we're
trying then and I'm trying to do again
it's like you know creating something
that feels just also completely Timeless
you know yeah I'm kind of excited about
this thing called Oppenheimer I believe
you might be you know collaborating I'm
just gonna say man listen pleasure to
talk with you thank you so much for your
work and I am looking forward to
Mandalorian season three Stephen it's a
pleasure I'm gonna watch Endor no no
listen the show is phenomenal like no
[ __ ] phenomenal I'm excited cool
have a great day all right you too